Does this work?
Am I vertical?
Am I wide?
I probably could be wide if I really wanted to be.
Wide, where?
Hello everybody!
Welcome to Kyoyuki.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's not spam, buddy.
Wide.
How do I be wide?
Hold on.
No, I'm long!
Wrong way!
I don't think I like being long.
I don't know, that's not wide.
That was a big stretch.
Everybody, posture check.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Poster check, posture check.
Oh, God, I can't stop getting long!
I'm so loud, I'm so loud.
Anyways, I'm here to sing.
Hold on.
I actually didn't really set up any of my stuff, so give me
one second.
We'll put this here.
And yeah, I hope you guys are having a good evening.
Oh, thank you for the donuts.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for the karaoke.
your voice is always a blessing to listen to you especially
when you sing thanks a lot thanks and lots of love extra
pair social just like you for real for real yes today today
uh our um mint and matara podcast episode two dropped so um
be sure to listen um i don't truly plan on uh streaming on
Mondays but I don't know usually usually when I'm in a sad
mood karaoke cheers me up and so I thought I could just do a
karaoke but this wasn't planned so true so yeah yeah yeah
yeah karaoke makes me feel feel good feel good feel good
feel good feel good feel good and I thought maybe now would
be a time to try shorts shorting I'm short I'm short
circuiting I'm uh uh what do I say wait what's the word wait
what am I what am I saying
songs only?
That would be kind of difficult.
What is the short song only?
I actually have no idea.
You're already short enough?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
But I'm thinking maybe going like an hour.
Oh, TV size.
Oh my gosh, yeah, I'll add in my TV size.
Dongo?
You know what?
Let's do it.
I haven't sung that song.
a long time wait oh no okay so i basically use this program
called joy sound on the switch i have to buy i have to buy
this by the 24 hours because it said that i had a hundred
free but I have I can only pick from a certain amount can
you do anime OPs I can I can sing whatever I want isn't that
so awesome oh my gosh I clicked on it and it already said 99
okay hold on if I I have the money so I just have to um
purchase it purchase the actually I'm only gonna purchase an
hour I don't know if that's worth the amount but you know
what Dango.
Do they not have it?
Okay, then never mind.
We're gonna find it on YouTube.
This is already working out really well for us, you guys.
Minty Mondays.
No, Mintara Mondays.
Daikazoku.
Uh, karaoke.
Let me make sure this one sounds good.
Okay, it sounds good.
Okay, first song.
Thank you.
Joy sound finds...
Oh, no.
Let me...
Oh, I don't...
It's okay, I told you I already have the finds.
Is this archived, boss?
Yeah.
Ooh.
Probably.
Okay.
Let me know if the audio is too low.
Four-tun-go-kushi-dango All, all, all, all together
100-north-northog Baby-dango-dango In the happy world, And
when you're more than 20 years old, Dango is my eyes are
thinning.
A nice dango, hands together, a big round, a big one, and it
will make a town.
A town is made of dango on the moon, we all together
That's what I get for thinking I remember the lyrics.
It's the opposite of yasa shi, it's kanashi.
How's the audio, by the way?
Thank you.
Okay.
It's like, it's over.
Blup.
Yay.
Yay, yay, yay.
Dangol Daikadoku from Klanad.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the Akato.
Thank you.
money thank you for the lovely performance we love you thank
you so much deadly nerd thank you oh my gosh it's way too
much it's way too much thank you
why did you do that to us what do you mean actually there's
another clanad song that i really oh sorry i didn't mean for
the double audio that i really love to sing let me see if
they have it um it's the it's the opening from the second
season um toky tokyo toky let me turn to tokyo
kizam oh my gosh my joyconic key let's see if they have it
oh i think that's it
is this it no no the lyrics are wrong I can probably find it
on YouTube though a karaoke of it go away how is this just
maybe this is just YouTube karaoke today instead of Joy-San
karaoke luckily I haven't bought the subscription yet so
Tokioki Zamu
let me see if this sounds good
okay it sounds good enough it sounds like a karaoke so it
doesn't sound like I won't get rather it sounds like a
karaoke so it sounds like I won't get copyrights
key karaoke night oh my gosh key songs are kind of tricky
because for some reason reason they're not really on like
joy sound and stuff maybe in actual Japan but for like these
for like the home one it's a lot of them aren't maybe we
will do key karaoke kind of fits the background it fits the
vibe right all right this is Tokyo Kizamu Uta from Klinad
also Klinad
you.
If you turn it back into it, look, it will start again.
I've just cut it down just by the way.
As soon as I go, I'll be able to enter it.
When you and me just go through the river in the middle of
the warmly warmly there were several of them I'll be here
today, I'm here, here, here is trying to remember me.
I'm here.
I love you, I love you.
I love you.
It will get far away from me I always remember everything,
everything, everything, One thing, one thing, one thing It's
an ordinary thing, but I'll show you how to shine It's so
much, one thing, It's always, it's always,
I've been singing this song in so long.
I'm there.
You only, you only are so many are you Oh my god, it's me,
it's me!
It's me!
I loved it.
I love you.
It's only you, it's only it's a song me me
I love me
day I I I Okay,
I gotta prepare myself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Tokyo Kizamu Uta from Kalanad.
Yippee!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you for the patty patty!
Thank you for the clapping!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the donuts as well, you guys.
Thank you so much, thank you, thank you.
Loved it when you sang Odoriko from Vondi.
Maybe I will sing it again tonight.
Who knows?
Without singing whatever I want.
Ninkyo Hime from Chowitz.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even remember how that goes.
I only remember the opening.
Like I think if I heard the ending, I would know it.
But if I...
Here I'm going to put on the BGM of...
Of even if we're not using it.
Joy Sound BGM.
Live shorts are a thing.
Yeah, isn't it crazy?
Yeah.
my soul your beats i wonder if they have that one on here
actually you know what let's just do youtube let's just
youtube it for some of these though i've got a want to do it
on joy sound just so i can change the key depending on the
song you know my soul your beats actually how does that song
go again Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do Are you just doing
any song today?
No, I'm just singing whatever we want.
Oh, J.
Fruits Basket.
Oh my god, that's a good one too.
Okay, I can try and sing this one, but I don't remember it
entirely.
Okay.
I think it'll come back to me if I hear it, you know?
Maybe, we'll see.
Okay, let's shut up Joy Sound.
This one should peek in.
Let me test it.
Okay, this sounds a little crunchy, but it kind of adds to
the old school anime vibe.
This isn't even that old of an anime, but.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
The bass is going crazy.
.
Okay,
I don't like this.
I don't like this instrumental at all.
Hold on.
I'm so sorry.
One more time.
This kind of wasn't so good.
You know what?
Let me check this one.
Oh, I'm afraid to use.
I'm afraid to use official instrumentals.
I'm afraid that YouTube is going to be like, hey, hey, hey,
no, no, no.
Oh, wait, let me see this one.
Okay, this one works much better.
Sorry, guys.
Radio.
Karaoke Planet.
Instrumental.
What is karaoke planet?
Is it like one of those YouTube channels that just has a
bajillion...
kiss kiss falling up oh my gosh you know what i've been
thinking of so much recently is the um is the ending for
oron oh my gosh it's so good
it's so good i think i I don't know.
I think I prefer it over the opening.
There's just something about it that's so like nostalgic
sounding about it.
It's so good.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, let's try this again.
I keep turning it up, only to feel like I'm gonna have to
turn it down again.
In the day of the morning, the night of the night, the
tiniest day will keep its way down.
In the classroom door, go through the room just a little
bit.
The morning is on my heart and I can walk out.
In such a daily life, the wind is the wind.
I heard it, I felt it felt it felt it felt like I felt it
felt like it was now in my own head and I felt it was a
great feeling that a few more stars
Was I supposed to start?
Hey, hey, hey I'm waiting
I'm waiting I'm calling I'm that's right now This time I'm
going to give it to I had a lot of memories, It was the
story The end of the end of the end The end of the world I
had to get out of You, I
feel like you're going out I feel like I felt, I felt like I
felt like I felt I feel like it's like a thousand of the
morning over the new day I feel like I'm waiting I feel like
I'm calling I feel like it's like this I'm feeling like it's
like it's
This is certified karaoke That's how you know This is real
This is the real deal
that was funny that was silly that was my soul your beats
here out here here um uh what's up saying it perfectly oh
thank you you're too quite kind not quite you're too kind oh
my gosh thank you for the 50 thank you so thank you for your
lovely singing man thank you oh thank you so much thank you
thank you
oh man you're singing is so beautiful thank you we're too
quiet
quine um oh final fantasy oh my gosh oh my gosh i wanted to
sing eyes on me last time so i'm going to I'm so excited I
love this song so much I have a question Are you a pick me
Am I a pick me What counts as a pick me No I think I'm I
think I would hope that I'm a girl's girl I think I'm a I
would like to think that I'm a girl's girl I'm like yeah you
go girl You go girl that's what i mean also welcome new
viewers i know that like with uh with um of being a short of
some some new i was gonna say strange no you're not strange
sorry we get a new audience so it's a little different than
usual but i think it's kind of fun to uh i think it's fun to
uh kind of get new people finding me as well right right i'm
mint i'm a vtuber i'm a ghost yeah i sing sometimes
oh my gosh wait has the new spice and wolf uh started i
think it has started airing hasn't it i haven't watched it
yet but i want to um because obviously spice and wolf it has
today oh my gosh wow wow oh wait wait two episodes are out
already oh my goodness holo is a vtuber i saw that oh my
gosh holo live it's crazy will this be archived uh i intend
on it being archived yes so um but it's all up to youtube hi
mint nice to meet you hi adam nice to me too too thank you
guys for all the donations i am reading them thank you thank
you thank you thank you okay eyes on me from from uh let me
check if this one's okay um but this is from final fantasy
okay it sounds good okay hold on where does it start okay
here we go i might have to turn it down though we'll see
Whenever I sang my songs On the stage, on my own Whenever I
said my words Wishing they would be heard I saw you smiling
at me Was it real or just my fantasy?
You'd always be there in the corner Of this tiny little bar
My last night here for you Same old songs, just once more My
last night here for you with you maybe yes maybe no I kind
of liked it your way how you shyly placed your eyes on me oh
did you ever know that I had mine
with that look on your face as if you're never heard as if
you're never down shall I be the one for you who pinches you
softly but sure if brown is shown then i will know that you
are no dreamer
so let me come to you close as i want to be close enough for
me to feel your heart be fast and stay there as I whisper
how I loved your peaceful flat eyes on me but did you ever
know that I had mine on you darling so share with me your
love if you have enough your tears if you're holding back or
pain if that's what it is how can I let you know more than
the dress and the voice just reach me out then
not dreaming darling so there you are with that look on your
face as if you're never heard as if you're never down shall
i be the one for you who pinches you softly but sure if
round is shown then I will know that you are no dream
I saw I saw someone in the chat said go dead girl go
something from full moon as the last day oh my gosh it's one
of my first ever videos i uploaded on youtube it's gone
forever now it's gone oh oh it's long long gone forever but
but i once sang a cover of from this from this uh oh wait i
think i just clicked it No, I don't want that one.
How does this one go again?
The early days.
It actually was the early days of YouTube.
I'll have to see how this one goes.
I don't remember.
Oh my god, my ears.
It's been so long since I have sang any of these before.
I can't.
snow may be the best what's myself i can't remember
oh i know this one i remember i remember i remember okay
okay okay i'll do this one myself from
Okay, it's gonna take me a second to get back into it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Where is the place where I was at?
That's where I was at.
Where was the place where I was?
In your eyes, in the eyes of that day, I found out that I
was looking for the other two.
Are you guys like me?
Oh, I'm so glad you're here.
Why do you like so much love me?
Your voice, the saddest is heard.
What have you ever been?
What has been your support?
I'm so far away and I'm not...
I don't think I'll remember the rest though.
Here, we'll do a short version of that one.
We'll just fade, fade, and fade out.
Here, here, I can do eternal snow though.
I know this one better.
Let's test the audio.
Holy bass.
first of a kind my my feelings just going to wakari and you
this this is I don't even I don't know about it, but It's
like the snow, but it's just a little bit free.
It's a story that's going to go.
Hold me tight, I love you, love me, love you.
I love somebody else.
I didn't know it.
I didn't know I love you.
I love you.
I don't mind any.
I'm so glad to be here.
I'm so glad I was so glad.
How long have you been thinking about it?
I just want to see how it's going to be.
I'm going to use my heart to light up the candle.
Now, I'm going to try to get it to go.
I'm going to hold my heart.
I'm going to hold it.
Oh, strong, strong Yogarashi, only if you can meet me But I
miss you I miss you Give me all the time Ami-cake no, this
muffler And I remember that part,
I love you
I wish I could show you what the background I've been
looking at on this video has been the whole time horses it's
been like horses and and like some of them look really goofy
because they're cartoon like or not cartoon they're like
statues of cartoon horses i don't understand why it was it
was distracting me so much snake eater cover when oh my gosh
did you want me to sing snake eater is that what you're
saying uh i i can't i'm not allowed no just kidding Okay, we
could do snake eater.
Let's sing it, baby.
What a thrill with darkness and silence through the night.
thrill I'm searching and I'm melting to you what a fear in
my heart but you're so supreme I give my life not for honor
but for you In my time There'll be no one else It's the way
I fly
I'm still in a dream Snake eat up And someday you go through
the rain Someday you feed on a tree rock This ordeal, the
trial to survive For the day we see new light I give my life
Not for honor but for you
My time There'll be no light
It's the way I'm
still in our dream, snake it up
I'm still in our dream, snake it up Snake it up
yeah snake snake eater yeah I
love saying that because if you press if you press the
button so like in the just the right way it will say sneeter
it's so funny what else do you guys want me to sing what
else what else oh thank you guys for the donos as well i'm
so sorry what is pink lady nagisa no simbad wait i think i
know that one but i don't oh my gosh dogs drink thank you
for the akadona thank you oh my gosh you're singing eternal
snow just snapped me out of an angsty funk today i'm ready
to take on the world again thank you i'm so glad i'm so glad
i'm so glad thank you guys for all the donos i really
appreciate Secret bass from Anohana Calling to the Night I
could try Sins of the Father Oh my god that song is so hard
It was so difficult I've never tried singing it so much But
like when I say that I mean like I tried singing it in my
room But I was being quiet Because I didn't know if my
neighbors would be able to hear me In Japan Let's see if
that calling to the night I didn't intend on this just being
Metal Gear, but we can try a couple of Metal Gear songs.
Let's do this one.
Let me see if this one's good.
Let me try this one.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, instrumental.
Here we go.
Let me check it.
Okay.
Hopefully it's good.
Wait, let me get the lyrics.
Calling to the night.
Oh, lyrics.
I forgot to write.
This is from Metal Gear Solid Portable Ops.
Yes.
Let's see.
Might have to adjust the volume a little bit, but that's
okay.
What is that sound?
It doesn't sound like that.
Through the night to the day, when everything is gone, carry
the soul away from the dry lands.
In the sun we see, Fighting over lines All our dreams and
wishes We send home for safekeeping Fighting for what's
right I know there's one part I always get the timing off on
So apologies in advance if I don't remember Calling to the
night to dream Again in the light Waiting for a storm to
rise And feel the isolation fleeting Calling to the night To
be Or not to be Leaving without you, leaving my soul behind
Calling to the night, colors of Kota Grove fade with time
Calling to the night for us, for every single time life.
All the ashes of men remain as a perfect memory, calling to
the night.
As a silhouette of time, hear the, hear the ringing echoes
in the splitting horizon, calling to the night
oh that one is so hard oh difficult that was calling to the
night for metal gear solid portable apps it's so it's really
tough song though it's hard for me to sing it even let's see
i hope people said sins of the father but
i'm gonna say down not as good as Dada Burke at all.
Simple and clean?
Okay, we can do that one next.
We'll do that one.
Wait, you mean simple and clean English, not what is the
Japanese one?
Hikari?
Right, right?
Wait, Japanese, yeah, which one are both?
Wait, I see a lot of people saying Hikari.
wait no i mean which one should i sing simple and clean or
hikari either one is good either spanish version oh oh i'm
gonna run it through google translate and just okay simple
and clean preferred okay i will do simple and clean but
before that i will do into the father oh gosh i'm really
nervous about don't okay if you were thinking of clipping
this please don't because i don't know if it'll be any good
okay okay okay oh gosh i think it starts right away wait
only when does it start in the deepest nights reaching out
fleeting memory all these thoughts keep piercing this broken
mind I fall but I'm still standing motionless far in the
distance there is light Light that burns these scars of old
All this pain reminds me of what I am I'll live, I'll become
all I need to be here Whoa,
whoa, whoa
Words that kill Would you speak them to me With your breath
so still It makes me believe In the Father's sins
Let me suffer now and never die I'm alive
Oh this song is so hard, oh my god
But I would listen to it all the time in Japan Like walking
to him from home Oh my god, it was like my power anthem
But I never got to practice it at karaoke so Pride feeds
their blackened hearts And the thirst must be quenched to
fuel hypocrisy Cleansing flames is the only way to repent
Renounce what made you words that kill
to me with your breath so still it makes me believe oh god
oh god the sins never die can't wash this blood off our
hands let the world fear us all it's just means to an end
our salvation lies
In the Father's sins Let me suffer now
In my heart I just light up the dark In his eyes
Oh gosh I've never sung that at all like like that like I
said whenever I would practice in my room it would be like I
would be like as quiet like like without like trying to sing
it but very quietly because I'm like what if my neighbors
can hear me what if like I'm like someone's outside and you
just hear me go whoa whoa whoa oh you should keep practicing
loud i'll try now that i'm back home i can uh at my maid
cafe i can keep practicing louder louder sorry sorry to all
my neighbors i only care what my neighbors in japan think i
guess also oh my gosh slid bunch of numbers thank you for
the akato no thank you for the song thank you thank you guys
for all the donos thank you so much love the streams
especially the karaoke you rejuvenated my passion for
drawing oh my gosh yammy thank you or or rather yes thank
you for the dono i'm so happy about your you coming back to
drawing sorry not sorry neighbors exactly exactly um waga no
kami-sama got
Waganok, waganokami-waganokami-sama.
Thank you guys for the donuts.
Rules of nature!
For the first time singing it, actually it sounded great.
Would woho again.
Those wohoes are really hard to...
And like, I love how Donna Burke, her voice, like, gets so
raspy.
So I, like, try to kind of do that, but I'm not good at it.
But, like, she has, like, such a powerful voice.
So I feel like mine is completely...
pales in comparison but that's okay it's all for fine right
i'm not a professional here where's this here for fine um
let me check up this one's good for simple and clean
no no i need it i need no no words no no utada hikaru backup
actually i might have to do let me do hikari let me type in
hikari but i'll sing simple and clean oh this is perfect
wait let me see I don't like the way it sounds though hold
on oh no you can hear the Hikari like vocals you know what I
mean like the don't know oh wait there's this guy Nashi okay
good good because it's the same in intro right let me check
let's listen to this one
Please, oh baby, don't go Simple and clean as the way that
you're making me feel tonight It's hard to let it go You're
giving me too many things lately You're all I need Oh, you
smiled at me And said, don't get me wrong, I love you But
does that mean I have to meet your father When we are older,
you're not And I said, no, I don't think life is quite that
simple away you don't hear me say please oh baby don't go
simple and clean it's the way that you're making me feel
tonight it's hard to let it go so simple and clean oh the
daily things like this and that What is what that keeps us
all busy?
Are confusing me?
That's when you came to me and said, Wish I could prove I
love you, but does that mean I have to walk a water?
When we are older, you'll understand it's enough.
When I say so And maybe some things are that simple When you
walk away You don't hear me say Please, oh baby Don't go,
simple and clean Is the way that you're making me feel
tonight It's hard to let it go Oh my god, my throat It's
morning is a little later on Regardless of warnings, the
future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before When
you walk away, you don't hear me say Please, oh baby, Don't
go, simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel
tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
Hold me, whatever lies beyond this morning is a little later
on.
Regardless of warnings, the future doesn't scare me at all.
Nothing's like before Hold me Whatever lies beyond this
morning Is a little later on Regardless of warnings The
future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before That's
a lie The future does scare me
I'm still recovering, recovering from a cold so I can't hit
high notes so easily right now.
So I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Yay!
That was simple and clean.
Simple and clean.
Could have fooled me.
What do you mean can't hit high notes?
I mean, I said I can't hit them as well.
Oh my gosh, good playlist.
Thank you for the 70.
Oh my gosh.
Dangment, your voice is so powerful.
Thanks for spoiling us with your voice.
Your voice is peaceful, soothing, and beautiful.
Thank you.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you guys for all the doughnuts.
Thank you.
Huh.
What could be next?
I can go for probably like another 20 minutes or so, so we
can do a couple more songs.
Songs.
I cannot borderline.
Okay, okay, okay.
I cannot.
Space Odyssey.
Oh my gosh, you know that not Space Odyssey.
Been singing this actually, sorry, I'm going to sing
something too that I want to sing also.
sexy thank you thank you for treating to treating to me that
taste of my childhood it's mine too it's mine too free run
ed oh my gosh that makes me want to bring up something okay
sorry i have a super unbased taste or unbased opinion i okay
so the other day i did karaoke and someone requested one of
the free run songs and i didn't recognize it and someone in
the comments was like she said you were in but she didn't
even know the name of the song i'm sorry i don't like well
okay the op is not as bad the ed i really love the chorus of
the ed but i cannot oh my god the song starts and i i'm so
sorry i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry oh no one of those types of no
no i am not I am typically not one of those types of people.
I am almost always a true believer in listening to the
opening and the ending every time.
But not the best Millet.
Millet, Millet is how you pronounce it?
Like when she starts and she goes, it's all right.
And then in the background, it goes, yeah, but I'm all
right.
I'm okay.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I just can't.
I can't.
can't I just oh there's something about it that really
literally like grates my spine like the chorus though is so
beautiful and I love it so much but just the beginning of
the song makes me be like okay next episode I'm sorry well
when you put it like that honestly fair I'm sorry I'm sorry
that it is an unbased opinion but you know I'm so based all
the time I have to have some unbased opinions right i can't
be perfect you guys geez
but this song this song is perfect You can see it.
Tingo fire, Bible white power, Tiger, tiger,
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
Look at each other, love love, love love, love each other
and look at them.
But I want to know more than I want to know, I'm so nervous
about it.
As I look at all the more weirds and as I think they become
so much more intense.
So I'm more into the unkind of the world.
Yeah, ah Love, love, love, love Love, love Love, love I
believe But it's so, so close, I'm gonna get it, it's gonna
be so Giri, giri, Giri, I can't go down Borderline, I can't
even see everything I can't see everything Giri, giri, giri,
Hi, Hi, Sarnalji, your mind My body is un- My body is un-
Unable I'll say it's-hallow Hey
Fuzzak 'e'a A-togged-togged I've been looking for That other
person And I want to see you again For the day I'm glad to
see you I'm glad to see you The lightest of the dark Yeah,
it's a big thing to see.
It's a big thing to see.
It's a dangerous line.
Ah, it's free, free, free, free, free, but if you don't
stop, stop, stop, stop, then you're gonna die, you're gonna
die.
Gini, gini, I'm a very dangerous,
One of my favorite things about this song is when they play
it at like any kura, like any anime song events.
When the chorus comes, people will break UOs, which are
really bright glow sticks and just it's called it's called
cycloning they just they just swirl them around a lot it's
so fun giri giri ai can't i pull that line
giri giri my saranarji eto
Look, the eyes work with it because of the song matter.
Sneaky.
not the giddy giddy eyes sure I'm serious I'm serious I'm
dead serious I'm always dead serious I'm dead serious
let's see what else what else thank you for the don't know
thank you it'd be interesting to sing hear you sing ace
combat songs when day maybe one day my partner heard you
kahan san ran into ikina borderline from the other room and
he said i'm glad she's back on her bullshit what do you mean
by that also shrimp thank you for the six jana thank you for
the fantastic voice you really helped me stay awake during
work oh good luck with work good luck good luck good luck
i'm gonna try singing this song it's not a japan or it's not
a anime song, I'm sorry.
But maybe, it's obviously, we can do whatever we want.
We don't have to do just anime songs, so.
I saw someone asking for Phantom of the Opera, but I
honestly don't think my voice can handle it today.
We'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
Maybe I can.
Who knows?
This song, I'm gonna try and do.
Usually I sing it.
Actually, maybe I shouldn't sing it.
I don't know.
Let me, I don't know.
I don't know, maybe I shouldn't sing this.
Maybe my voice isn't good for this either.
I don't know.
Uh, you know what, whatever.
I can sing whatever I want.
Do it, Mick, Gamba, okay.
Take a break and sing Tequila.
No, we only have, I only plan on singing not very much
longer anyway, so.
Just have fun.
Yeah, we're just having fun with it.
You can sing whatever you want.
Yeah!
But, uh, yeah, I'll try it.
I'll try it.
sound good I'm really sorry but I love this song this is
another song that I would listen on repeat all the time when
I was in Japan so I'm basically singing a couple of my
comfort songs well since of the father was a comfort song
this is a comfort song what else did I listen to sing the
carpenter song was a car comfort song so okay I'm gonna try
and sing this one this is Mariana Cross by Ghost.
But I can't tell if the key will be okay for me.
We'll see.
We were speeding together down the dark avenues.
But besides all the stardom, all we got was blues.
But through all the sorrow, we were riding hard.
And the truth of the matter is I never let you go, let you
go.
We were scanning the cities, walking to greater dues.
But besides all the glamour, all we got was bruised.
But through all the sorrow, we were riding high.
And the truth of the matter is I never let you go, let you
go.
You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
Not just another bloody Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
choose to run away with me.
I will tickle you internally.
And I see nothing wrong with that.
Marineris Oz.
We were searching for reasons to play by the rules.
But we quickly found out it It's just for fools.
But the wrong, the sorrow will be riding high.
And the truth of the matter is I'll never let you go, let
you go.
Never gonna let you go, chat.
You go down just like Holy Mary.
Mariana, Mariana Cross, not just another bloody Mary,
Mariana, Mariana, Mariana, you go down just like Holy Mary,
Mariana, Mariana Cross, your beauty never ever scared me,
Mariana, Mariana, Mariana Cross, if you choose to run.
away with me.
I will tickle you internally.
And I see nothing wrong with that.
Nothing wrong with that.
I can't help.
I know it's sad.
oh i thought i knew i i i was like i don't think my throat
will be able to handle it this time i don't have any water
either so oh wait have a little bit of tea left stay
hydrated everybody my i say as i drink my first drink in an
hour and a half okay so if i can't do that i don't know if i
could do it okay you know what found the opera if my let's
see let's see what is um what is a phantom of the opera song
just the original phantom of the opera is here inside my
mind that one or another or any just a phantom of the opera
song short-ish not really Think of me?
All I ask of you?
The one you like the most?
The point of no return?
That song is dirty!
Let me see if this one's good.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Let me see if the man speaks.
No, I don't want it to be a solo.
All I ask of you.
you karaoke female part only gosh i love youtube you sing
raoul no no no no christine part christine part only
instrumental christine no no raoul part oh wait oh i'm i
should put in male part only i put in the wrong thing okay
i'm i don't know who this Clark on stage guy is, but I'm
using your work.
Thank you very much.
It says sing along with me, so hopefully he sounds good.
I believe in him.
He's got a lot of subscribers.
I'm still standing.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Go ahead, Clark.
Oh, no, this is the intro.
Go on, Clark.
Do your thing!
Eventually.
Okay, okay, he's starting.
He's good.
He's gonna do it.
No more talk of darkness.
Oh my god.
Forget these wide-eyed dreams.
He's beautiful.
I'm here.
Nothing can harm me.
My words will warm and calm you.
Oh, sorry.
I thought this was my part.
dry your tears I'm here with you beside you to guard you and
to guide you say you love me every waking moment turn my
head with talk of summertime say you need be with you now
and always.
Promise me that all you say is true.
That's all I ask of you.
Let me be your shelter.
Oh, he interrupted me.
That's fine.
Let me be your life.
You're safe.
No one will find you.
Your fears are far behind you.
All I want is freedom, a world with no more night, And you
always beside me, to hold me and to hide me.
Say you'll share with me one love, one lifetime.
Let me lead you from your solitude.
Say, oh, lead me with you here beside you Anywhere you go,
let me go too Christine, that's all I ask of you Say, oh,
share with me one love, one life time say lord and i will
follow you say each day with me each night each morning say
you love me thanks clark love me that's all i ask Wait, I
don't remember them.
Love, love me.
Okay.
I started laughing because I thought I was going to be
singing with him.
Why is he looking at me like that?
He wants me to continue.
Oh, here we go.
Can you let me go?
Love me That's all Wait, why are you so quiet?
You
I can't ever sing this song seriously Oh, sorry, Clark You
sang beautifully I was laughing because Oh my gosh, I was
laughing because There's I thought I was supposed to be
singing with him in the chorus, but it was just him.
I realized because it said, okay, it said like, now we both
sing this part.
And I was like, oh no, I just sang over him before when I
wasn't supposed to.
And it made me laugh.
Whoopsie.
Hopefully that was good enough for you guys.
Okay, I think I can do one more song.
One more song.
i don't know what to sing at all um and thank you for the
donuts you guys when's the album coming out stop it stop it
can you do koino yoku shi yoku koino yoku shioku i let me
practice it a couple more times bad apple
golden hour i would have to put the what's it called the
pitch up though and i can't do that on youtube
but bad apple is a good song i never said it was a bad song
ah that's also a really hard song for me to sing i have no i
need too song any too song
i ship mint and clark now please don't please don't
lion not like that one oh i don't know oh my gosh oh diamond
crevice you know i will sing that one because i was supposed
to sing it before oops diamond crevice carolket there we go
i was supposed to sing that or someone asked for that one
last time i said i would but
okay break stuff I'm not trying to break my throat today we
will do we will sing break stuff one day don't worry don't
worry don't worry don't worry one day one karaoke we'll sing
break stuff
this is diamond crevice from macros Oh
It's long, long goodbye Sayonara Sayonara I don't know.
I know how many times I'll be telling myself to be unjustly
and give it to myself.
My love is my love, my heart is my strength.
I love you.
I love you all.
And there are all there are many moments.
What do you need?
What does it mean?
I love you.
The worlds of the world are gone.
Oh, it's long, long, goodbye Sayonara, sayonara, Oh my
god, Leah!
Oh my god, Leah!
Why
do you think all this?
The drop fire
Michelle!
Thank you very much!
That was the last song, Thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you.
This was your first time seeing me.
I'm Mint.
I'm a VTuber and I play games and I sing sometimes.
I'm a spooky ghost.
So if you want to subscribe, that'd be pretty cool.
We have lots of fun here, don't we guys?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
First time here, shot up, Miguel.
Thank you.
When...
Oh, Rock for Rabbit.
Thank you for the Okaduro.
Thank you for the karaoke cheer me up a ton.
Hope you feel better too.
I can never get enough of your amazing voice and I can never
express how glad I am.
You're back.
Mr. Olives, thank you so much.
Yeah, Hariminto-chan Iko Eiyano.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hello, hello.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
See you when I see...
Oh, tomorrow I'll have a stream.
I'll be playing a spooky horror game.
So, yes.
Let's play spooky, spooky game.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye-bye-bye.
Otz Minto!
Otz Minto.
Bye!